[Música]
bienvenidos a este noticiero especial de
france 24 cierre blanco como siempre es
un gusto para mí acompañarlos puede que
para muchos sea un reto imposible pero
nuestro últimos 15 minutos les vamos a
contar las buenas noticias de este 2020
porque a pesar de la pandemia de kobe 19
en todo el mundo han seguido llegando
las noticias de esperanza comenzamos de
inmediato con nuestros titulares
el 2020 termina con el inicio de las
vacunaciones masivas contra el hobbit 19
una noticia histórica que da esperanzas
a la población mundial para superar una
pandemia que llegó a confinar a más de
la mitad del planeta la vuelta a la
normalidad está cada vez más cerca
este 2020 ha traído consigo la
consecución de derechos especialmente
para las mujeres en sudán se prohibió la
mutilación genital femenina
kamala harris se convirtió en la primera
vicepresidenta de la historia de eeuu y
la confederación brasileña de fútbol
igual los salarios entre hombres y
mujeres
y france24 escoge a sus tres personas
inspiradoras latinoamericanas del año
2020 las son las siguientes gonzález o
moratorio biólogo uruguayo clave en
frenar al hobbit 19 en su país la
mexicana lady pets apicultor e indígena
maya ganadora del premio goldman 2020 y
la colombiana claudia lópez primera
alcaldesa el fbi de américa latina
[Música]
comenzamos entonces porque si hay una
noticia que está permitiendo que el
ánimo de la población mundial pueda
acabar este 2020 en alto es la que tiene
que ver con la vacuna contra el cob y 19
el inicio de la vacunación en la
población permite soñar con la
posibilidad de volver a la normalidad en
algún momento del próximo 2021 y para
hablar sobre esta gran noticia nos
acompaña el doctor pedro gargantilla
jefe de medicina interna del hospital el
escorial y profesor de historia de la
medicina en la universidad francisco de
vitoria doctor gargantilla gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros como profesor de
historia de la medicina cómo se explica
que hayamos conseguido una vacuna en
menos de un año teniendo en cuenta que
para la gripe española se necesitaron
más de 20 años
estamos en un momento histórico nunca
antes en la historia de la medicina
hemos ido tan rápido en el avance de una
vacuna la verdad es que se responde a
varios factores uno de ellos es que
nunca antes la comunidad científica
había remado en la misma dirección es
decir tenemos muchos grupos de trabajo
que están investigando en diferentes
aspectos de la vacuna eso no se produjo
por ejemplo cuando se inventó la vacuna
de la gripe el segundo hecho el
coronavirus no es un virus nuevo lo
conocíamos lo que no conocemos en el
saps comptos es decir ya había grupos de
trabajo estudiando antes de la aparición
de la vacuna y lo tercero y también creo
que es un dato muy importante hemos
compartido toda la información desde el
principio se compartió todos los avances
que se van produciendo se empezaron las
fases dos y las fases tres cuando
todavía no se ve el vídeo de la fase 1
es decir se fueron superponiendo las
fases en el desarrollo de la vacuna para
que todo fuera mucho más rápido
el doctor pero más allá de la vacuna de
kobe 19 qué importancia han tenido las
vacunas a lo largo de la historia
las vacunas se han modificado
sustancialmente el curso de la historia
la primera vacuna fue la de edward
jenner la vacuna contra la viruela y
conseguimos erradicar por primera vez en
la década de los 70 del siglo pasado una
enfermedad es un hito fundamental las
vacunas han supuesto que enfermedades
por ejemplo como la poliomielitis que
hace 20-30 años veíamos muchas secuelas
en países occidentales eso ha
desaparecido que es una cosa anecdótica
que las secuelas que nos dejaban décadas
como la parotiditis el sarampión
tampoco aparezcan en el primer mundo
porque estados vacunados es decir hemos
conocido un estado de bienestar gracias
a las vacunas que antes siglos atrás no
se conocía
ahora usted está acostumbrado a realizar
lo que significaron las vacunas del
pasado desde la distancia y el tiempo
como eran esta vacuna de kobe 19 cuando
estudian esta pandemia en un futuro
yo creo que estamos viviendo por momento
histórico yo que me dedico a dar clase
de historia de medicina nunca pensé que
fuera a formar parte de la historia es
decir dentro de 10 años estos se
analizarán como entonces estamos
analizando la famosa gripe española de
hace un siglo como se comercializará
bueno yo creo que nos analizarán como
sociedad hemos cometido muchos errores
como sociedad lo estamos viendo pues
algo estos últimos meses se está
recomendado de los ministerios
comunidades científicas que la sociedad
lleva a cabo las tres emes la distancia
de seguridad el lavado de manos las
mascarillas no estamos haciendo caso las
recomendaciones es decir eso será una
crítica cuando nos analicen como nos
hemos comportado tenemos cosas buenas
las cosas buenas es que hemos remado
todos en la misma dirección y que
diferentes países han contribuido al
desarrollo pues de los diferentes
equipos y de las diferentes vacunas que
tenemos
doctor ya para finalizar podemos decir
que esta es la buena noticia sin duda de
este año
yo creo que sí hemos conseguido una
vacuna en un tiempo récord recordemos
cómo estábamos pues en los meses de
marzo y abril tenemos a un tercio de la
población mundial confinada a la
aparición de la vacuna se veía como algo
muy lejano nadie apostaba en aquellos
momentos que antes de finales del 2020
tuviéramos una vacuna y lo hemos
conseguido yo creo que la comunidad
científica se puede dar por satisfecha
así es doctor gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en france24 y como
nos comentaba el doctor gargantilla la
importancia de las vacunas para
erradicar enfermedades es fundamental en
ese sentido 2020 también nos ha dejado
buenas noticias en la lucha contra los
virus el 25 de agosto la oms se
declaraba áfrica libre de polio después
de que nigeria estuviera cuatro años sin
detectar un caso así fue el histórico
anuncio de la uem s hasta folles después
de cuatro años sin casos de polio
salvaje la región africana de la oms ha
sido declarada libre del virus usual
polio barras
además de la polio otra enfermedad que
afecta especialmente a áfrica es el
ébola el 18 de noviembre el ministro de
salud de la república del congo anunció
el fin del undécimo brote de la epidemia
del ébola después de 42 días sin casos
positivos un logro que también ha
contado con el uso de vacunas y me
complace declarar solemnemente el fin de
la undécima epidemia de la enfermedad
del virus del ébola en la provincia de
ecuador de la república democrática del
congo
cambiamos el foco y nos centramos en los
logros en materia de igualdad 2020
también podemos celebrar avances en
consecución de derechos para las mujeres
gracias al fin de prácticas abusivas la
igualdad salarial e incluso en nuevos
horizontes para las mujeres trans para
conocer más sobre estos ejemplos veamos
el informe de luís muñoz
el avance hacia la igualdad empieza con
la eliminación de prácticas que ponen en
peligro la salud de las mujeres en sudán
tras la caída del dictador omar al
bashir el país entró en una fase de
democratización entre las nuevas medidas
llegó la criminalización de la
mutilación genital femenina 30 años
después
nuestras madres y nuestras abuelas creen
que la circuncisión femenina es una
especie de placer y que supone una vida
matrimonial feliz para la niña pero es
una mala tradición
más allá de la erradicación de estas
prácticas ser una referencia puede
inspirar a niñas de todo el mundo en
eeuu kamala harris se ha convertido en
la primera vicepresidenta electa de la
historia también será pionera por ser
afro y asiática
en the night state
la política es un buen espacio para
romper techos de cristal y el deporte lo
es para luchar contra la desigualdad la
potencia futbolística de brasil anunció
la igualdad salarial entre el fútbol
masculino y el femenino
es decir ya no existe una brecha de
género en términos de remuneración entre
hombres y mujeres a su vez está atrás
la confederación brasileña de fútbol
está tratando a hombres y mujeres por
igual absolutamente por igual bueno
también este 2020 ha sido un año de
consecución de derechos para las mujeres
trans petra de schutter se convirtió en
bélgica en la primera ministra trans de
la unión europea estoy orgullosa de que
en bélgica y en la mayoría de la unión
europea tu identidad de género no te
define como persona ni es un problema
espero que mi nombramiento como ministra
y vice primer ministra pueda
desencadenar el debate en países donde
todavía no es así son algunos ejemplos
de avance en los derechos de las mujeres
un progreso que esperamos que en 2021
sea aún mayor
y continuamos con más consecución de
derechos desde 2010 en el año en que
argentina de forma pionera en la región
legalizó el matrimonio homosexual cada
vez más países se han sumado a la
aprobación de las uniones entre personas
del mismo género en este mapa veamos la
situación de américa latina' y podemos
ver además de argentinas países como
brasil colombia ecuador uruguay y
algunos estados de mexico también a
chile aunque lo nombra unión civil este
año se han sumado los países más
a esta lista primero fue costa rica y el
segundo bolivia que lo celebró la
primera unión en este mes de diciembre
un matrimonio que de forma legal en el
país se conoce como unión libre en 2021
tanto cuba como venezuela han mostrado
intenciones de convertirse en los
siguientes países que legalicen estas
uniones en esta consecución de derechos
para la región unas declaraciones del
papá francisco en el documental
francesco causaron gran revuelo
internacional después de que el
pontífice apoyarse las uniones civiles
del matrimonio pero inéditas desde el
vaticano
lo que tenemos que crear es una ley de
unión civil de esa manera están
legalmente cubiertas yo lo he defendido
y mucho se ha hablado del factor
medioambiental a la hora de explicar el
surgimiento de pandemias las cuales
están estrechamente ligadas a la
destrucción de hábitats y que además
empeoran el cambio climático sin embargo
en este 2020 también se han conseguido
buenas noticias desde el plano ecológico
veamos
la pandemia del cob y 19 ha eclipsado
los retos climáticos sin embargo el año
termina con esperanza para el medio
ambiente con noticias como la promesa
del presidente electo de eeuu joe biden
de volver a los acuerdos del clima y
tras el abandono del presidente trump
hoy hace cinco años el mundo se reunió
para adoptar los acuerdos de parís
contra el cambio climático y en 39 días
a eeuu se va a volver a sumar
el multilateralismo también necesita de
responsabilidad individual como es el
caso de dinamarca que anunció el fin de
la extracción de combustibles fósiles
para 2050 pero más allá de promesas
futuras el presente también da señales
de cambio las renovables vivieron uno de
sus mejores años en la primera mitad del
2020 en la unión europea se generó más
electricidad renovable superando por
primera vez a la utilizada por los
combustibles fósiles según la consultora
ember el kobe 19 cambio el consumo pero
también los usos habituales como
demuestra la revolución de la bicicleta
con países de todo el mundo aumentando
los carriles y fomentando su utilización
un respiro verde para las ciudades es
muy urgente ahora que haya espacio para
moverse y no solamente en coche sino
también andando o en bicicleta sobre
todo porque la mayoría de los
desplazamientos que se hacen en ciudad
son de menos de 8 kilómetros en menos de
8 km
un medio de transporte más eficaz es la
bicicleta cambios de tendencia
ilusionantes pero necesarios y es que en
2021 todavía han de ser mayores porque
la lucha climática ya se encuentra en
una carrera contrarreloj antes de
concluir este informativo de las buenas
noticias de 2020 queremos presentarles
una selección de france 24 de los tres
personajes latinoamericanos del año son
personas que nos han inspirado por lo
que las consideramos una buena noticia
para el mundo en este ranking no puede
faltar el doctor uruguayo gonzalo
moratorio que fue reconocido por la
revista 'nature' como una de los días
investigadores más importantes de 2020
entre sus logros desarrollar un test de
diagnóstico barato y efectivo que ayudó
a que uruguay sea uno de los países que
mejor ha contenido la pandemia
el mensaje
haber mostrado que tal vez la ciencia es
tan importante como la actividad
financiera de la cual por ejemplo uno
necesita para funcionar cualquier tipo
de actividad en el mundo también nos
inspira lady page y ganadora del premio
woman en el 2020 el conocido como novel
de medio ambiente y que comparte con
otras cinco personas conocidas como la
guardiana de las abejas por luchar
contra la soja transgénica y también
conseguir que el estado mexicano revocar
a los permisos a la multinacional
monsanto
se empezó a abrir la frontera agrícola
para poder sembrar la soya y esto hasta
hoy en día aún se sigue deforestando y
aún sigue creciendo
claudia lópez alcaldesa de bogotá en
colombia dirigiendo una población
superior a los 7 millones se posesionó
el primero de enero y es referente por
ser la primera mujer en liderar la
capital colombiana y además por el
añadido de ser la primera alcaldesa el
fbi y américa latina
para posicionarme como la primera mujer
mujer diversa
está como alcaldesa mayor en él
y así llegamos al final de este especial
informativo sobre las buenas noticias de
2020 lo dejamos con unas imágenes
finales con momentos que nos han
emocionado de forma positiva durante el
año veamos
ah
[Música]
aquí
son
es la
y me fui
[Música]
inusual y también emocionante años sigue
con más información en france 24 horas
24 puntos com hasta la próxima
[Música]